yeah canada or should i call you
karen no you definitely shouldn't but
you can if you'd like to
today we're checking out karen's
yeah do you know what a karen is of
course you do everyone knows what a
carrot is no but pl please tell me in
your own words what i care about what
oh it was interesting how does one
define karen
why not to look at video more effective
oh
yeah pictures a thousand words but a
video oh my
okay we'll start with this one great
quality by the way better than my videos
in new york city and i'm so excited to
get whoa hey
i'm walking here i'm really excited to
people i mean listen to me we don't talk
like that we don't say things like that
you understand
do you understand hey sorry
forget about it you think that's real
forget about it
i thought that was fake uh i mean i
don't know
new york is full of full of some
fantastic people
that yeah it's known for people's like
attitudes and stuff
like hey we don't talk like that it
speaks exactly like that
like i was like okay
there's some high level karen's in new
york you got to be careful you never
know
listen to me we don't talk like that we
don't say things like that you
understand
do you want to think sorry
damn she does talk just like it we don't
talk about it
we talk like that but you but you are
like
karen's work on a different level of
logic we cannot comprehend it
okay this one i've seen it's great what
do you do
i like her now that's it you're in there
you think you got me she got
she locked him in that's what you get
little wait this isn't even your
property you can't just lock me in here
i could do whatever i want you never
tell a karen what they can't do
i can do whatever i want i should do
whatever i want
and now i'm gonna leave
with those fumes and i can't even she
say
he infects her lungs with those things
because he blows them there
oh my god that's the logic she's uh yeah
30 sets what are you she out of breath
oh right
did you see that speed
i never saw that
oh god i better get out of here
don't never catch me running one mile an
hour
what are you i'm gonna get
she ran in lowercase
or her lungs were infected you know she
couldn't run very fast just had a breath
here's the classic aaron please tell me
you haven't seen this
dude i've i haven't watched the clip but
i've seen like screenshots of this
lady's creepy face this is
a level 500 cameron bust i mean just
look at her face
it's okay i'm sorry he apologized it's
[Applause]
oh my god look at her face dude demon
damon satan
how do they become like this how do
karen's get spawned
where do they come from i i believe it
comes from when they
they they're upbringing their mother
wasn't caring and they have inherited
not genetically
but just through their the rearing as a
child and once the child gets old enough
to leave the nest
they are finally in control their lives
and they unleash their caring
upbringing upon the world and no one can
stop them so there's a nest of
carrots where they're all spawned got it
right right it's it's it's in the water
it's similar to a kraken but it's a
cairn instead
it's like a bloodborne boss or something
burned the national terrorists
apologize instead of being a [ __ ]
you're calling me sorry but you're
calling me a [ __ ]
set an example sorry my kids can't
hear me calling you a [ __ ] your
window's open they can't hear me because
they're listening to kids bop
yes
so kids pop is what makes people become
characters
that's all the kids mop she has to
listen to those kids songs over and over
and over again with the modified lyrics
she can't handle it anymore
in sweden we didn't have kid spot but we
had the smurfs did you have that
yeah we had smurfs yeah yeah the smurf
sings it's like pop classics but they're
sung by the smurfs
no no we have we have we have the
chipmunks
i guess it's probably better well they
take the song they turn up like me
yeah it's the exact same thing yeah okay
yeah that's [ __ ]
there on the way to school me and my
sister like that police
you gotta play the smurfs hits man oh my
goodness that [ __ ]
god bless my dad for listening to that
garbage in the morning thank you
what a hero okay another karen yeah
she's asked we're gonna call
we'll call the cops through but we just
stand right here
[Music]
oh they're washing her crayons
oh
a little girl trying to just draw oh my
god
wow that is next level karen
soulless this
they're soulless beings yeah i don't
understand like
there's no way there's no way these
people actually have their own kids
because they are just monsters oh my god
oh we're out here in a public parking
space yeah but you've drawn the ground
alright get the water hose out
we got to get this and make you watch
like where's where's her actual parents
that i hope they slap the taste at both
their mouths jesus christ
damn daddy daddy ken came out i don't
know
people that treat kids like this yeah
stupid like they just didn't have their
own childhoods they got taken out on
other people
i would get that hose and spray that
carrot
be careful like it will reveal her
monstrous face underneath layers of
ketone makeup
oh man don't look at the mess
oh my god yeah that that's too that's
too caring for me even
all right moving on are you serious for
what
citizens are right okay i'll move my car
no no you're not moving your car we're
staying right here till the cops come no
i'm gonna move myself i don't know
you're saying right here
stop filming me don't fail me
stop filming me
i love that okay so i'll move my car no
because that would fix the problem
this is citizen's arrest i'm going to
rescue you inside my car he says the
rest is the funniest [ __ ] if this isn't
kingdom
citizen's arrest try me [ __ ]
these are good
i like these very names i don't even i
almost feel like it's not even real at
the end because she sounds like she's
about to crack up stop filming me
no recording me now
hey internet this man in this doberman
just attacked me and my chihuahua it's
not a joke
doberman what are you doing
no he did it
okay is this real this can't be real i
don't know no way
i think there's a level of like
entitlement to like especially
the to old women like this like oh you
got the camera on me
oh yeah well i'm going to show you now
your dog bit me they just like make it
out of themselves
get away from me what is wrong with you
hey i have seen you around this
neighborhood too many
times this is ridiculous your car is
insanely loud
no no no no no there are
children that live in this neighborhood
their ears can explode
your car is so loud oh my gosh kids are
so bothered by noise all the time that's
why they make so low noise themselves
kids are definitely quiet
the kids are trying to have their quiet
time stop by being so loud
like i can almost sympathize with this
lady a little bit depending on like what
the rest of the context is
like video is just her being mad but if
they're like going around the like
place the whole time revving their
engine and showing off and
like imagine if you got like a bunch of
bikers living down your street and
they're just like doing like the south
park thing remember
everything absolutely but there's two
ways to approach a problem like this you
could be like hey man
uh would you mind like not driving
around here all the time you're making a
lot of noise could you maybe go
somewhere else
right yeah she should definitely not
have the correct place
oh my god what's with the kids oh my god
okay all right this is
i was in the wrong in this story i will
admit that i did lightly bump the car in
front of me
like barely touched it okay barely
and the woman drops out of the car and
she goes
there are children in this car how could
you
what [ __ ] difference does he make i
barely touch your car
you just give her your here's my
insurance information give him a call
no because i didn't even like it was
like
it was like insurance for what it's like
a
like road rage i guess you did something
in the car i don't [ __ ] care oh they
got their seat belts out are they okay
i'm so sorry are they okay should i call
enameling i thought you was gonna say
she
she flopped out of the car like holding
her neck like oh my neck i'm injured i'm
suing you or something yeah
no this ain't america [ __ ] come on i
looked at my rear view mirror and saw
your pewdiepie and i thought yeah
[Music]
oh my god did you pay taxes yeah
everybody pays no i don't [ __ ] you it's
like we also pay this thing called
federal taxes in america that goes
towards like everywhere so
you know whatever all right i gotta see
this
are they gonna stay there watching us
the whole entire time all right
away from my property we're literally
away from your property oh my goodness
gracious
you're on the sidewalk you don't own the
sidewalk
oh my god is she literally a kid yeah
seriously we don't need anything i can
ask you anymore you are getting way too
close
[Music]
nobody's surprised yeah
you already have it whoa big surprise
shucker right there some of them are
just upsetting i don't know i like the
cringy one
i want the camera
i need your name oh you just did it on
the illegal boom
then you always work here alone what's
your name number norma k
you count that all the time i have never
been here
that's a lie
[Laughter]
you're a photographer give me the car
give me your card you're here there
queen get out
don't march
what is happening i don't know she's
just yelling at him
this is funny watching people be angry
thing oh god you didn't like the phone
camera what did we do wrong you're one
trespassing
two illegal photographs three you're not
allowed
[Laughter]
for another reason
what the hell no you're not you're doing
it again till i do something to stop it
you want to give me your name can you
explain your story
jack wait what hamilton
oh [ __ ] okay they always want your name
right what's your name what's your name
they told her they told her a different
name she didn't even remember it because
youtube is yelling
[Laughter]
do you hear a lot of these people in
america no i've never actually seen all
these people in real life
no because you know it's america
america brings cairns like no other
country
on a sunday have you got nothing
better to do we are prepared to start
work from 8 am on the weekend
i mean we've got a crack on are we going
to get in the neck from the bus
yeah fair enough we started a bit early
but you know i don't see what the
problem is
my son is a lawyer and this is breaking
noise pollution laws oh
our son is a lawyer with a new ball
oh no not the child look at the children
doing this for the babies this is for
the babies not for me
at all give them a load of stress
well if you're causing them stress they
can tell me they're causing you stress
i don't mind starting a bit later we can
ask the client just happy with it
that's fine it's your client the woman
who lives here
yeah right i'll speak to are they
the way she speaks right i'll have a
bottle of water
early it's not just going to bank that
hard is it look i'll bang on this door
as hard as i want
don't you tell me what
you want to do
what is going on here just ignore i just
crack on with the job
uh excuse me what did you say starting
polly to crack on with the job
i don't think so
i'm calling the police okay that's fine
we've got a license so we'll just
we'll work with it we'll tell them that
we're allowed to
did you give these men permission to
start work here
at this time on a sunday morning
on a sunday you're absolutely disgusting
to be fair that's absolutely disgusting
to be fair it is very irritating when
they start so early especially on a
weekend
yeah i don't wanna hear what you gotta
get done you know like yeah but come on
you can
on a weekend you don't have to start at
eight i kind of get it but
the reaction is no way justified
whatsoever
[Music]
trust me she's offload she takes her
ladder
because they can't get down i've done
one i don't make i'm not jumping down
there
i don't know how we're gonna get down
she's just ridiculous
what's going on we can't even do it
shut the client why we took our ladders
she comes back if you stop
working it's not how it's gonna work
you just give us the ladders back oh
we'll just call the police
i'll give you the ladders back if you
stop working oh it's gonna work
[Music]
we're stuck on the road oh man
all right fine we'll just call the
police i don't think you can reason with
this kind of person yeah
just let me know all right then have fun
what did she say no she was all right
actually yeah
she told me that i'll paint her sitting
next week because she was fine
you know what her problem was a lot more
what a gal she went home and was
embarrassed like oh my god
i don't think so i'm gonna take your
ladder
actually the internet is probably the
best thing to come back karen keep
saying just put him up
publicly my yeah my favorite was karen's
themselves film and they don't realize
that they're being the karen yeah
guys sounds like complete twits we're
twins
you're the one coming up to two young
girls getting mad at them for picking
berries years old
six years old because we wanted to eat
some berries i'm saying eat all the
berries you want just don't take the
bush with you
i'm sorry
of berries why don't you mind your own
business why don't you mind your own
business
you know that is the [ __ ] rudest
thing you've said to me you decided
just got the karen cut
no i'm not okay yeah call me you're a
colonizer you're
european most likely yeah where did you
come from
the u.s u.s yeah oh so you're not
canadian either
yeah yeah but we were canadian i was
born here i was born here too okay
were you born here why okay the people
filming are kind of cringe yeah what the
[ __ ] this is karen versus karen
jesus christ the ladies and the ladies
like yeah eat the berries just don't
pick the whole berry plant because
the berries can regrow and they're like
well where are you from
like jesus christ
this is actually like i was born here
and you're not even born in here oh my
god
i was born a year ago oh my god do you
pay your taxes
do you pay taxes i pay my taxes here and
that gives me authority to be an [ __ ]
is that slimer
[Music]
no karen you're holding up the line i
need my mint chicken in mine make
nuggets
get out the wine there
oh [ __ ] stop that karen i need my food
to get more fatter
yeah get out of here oh again
it's funny but the dude's also being
carried again yeah that's a lot of karen
versus karen
you're yelling back you lose
do you ever watch your car ken
go go in and tell yeah somebody can go
in and tell somebody
[Music]
[Laughter]
i can't wait until she starts that car
it's so good
the urgency and they're like okay this
is funny we should film my brother we
need to tell her
we should tell her we need to tell her
she's gonna she's gonna crank the car
the spark club's gonna spark and it's
gonna be it's gonna be over with
[Laughter]
i think it's enough karen clips for
today but if you don't
like those girls good check out ken oh
also
ken yes wouldn't it be great if
every time you bought something you get
another of that thing
two things i mean endless
endless tell me more
right now g fuel has bogo sale bogo
not because it's boggers bogos but
because you buy one
you get one free
[Music]
oh my god i gotta get some what code do
i use
no code required my dude but if you want
to be epic about it you can
you can enter that pewdiepie code in
there
give me some right now it's a great way
to stock up
if you want to get some g fuel it's the
biggest sale of the year so now it's
your chance
check that link in the description thank
you ken for joining check out can look
at craft and bye bye
don't be karen
don't do it
[Music]
i got something for you
[Applause]